- I got an email that said,
"Hi. I am from the Spatial Orientation
Laboratory at Brandeis University.
"Would you like to go in our space chair?"
Yes, yes I would.
- The lab does a whole
variety of different things.
Space research, spatial orientation,
how does a person know
where they are in space?
We also look at artificial gravity,
we look at human postural balancing,
sensory motor adaptation and processing,
we do some sorts of modelling as well,
and we've had a history of
looking at motion sickness.
There's a lot that we don't know
about when does spatial
disorientation happen
and how can we resolve it?
- That went wrong, that went wrong. Okay.
- The first question of this project
is can we recreate essentially
what an astronaut would experience,
that sort of weak sense of gravitational cues
and the spatial disorientation,
on Earth?
And the way we do it, is we
put people into this beast, this machine,
we blindfold them so they can't use
their visual system,
noise cancelling headphones
so they can't use their auditory system.
They're just falling to
the left and to the right.
And because they're tilting
relative to gravity,
you can use information
about how you are relative
to gravitational vertical
to figure out where you are.
You're getting this information
a little bit through your
skin as you push against that seat,
but a lot through your vestibular system.
- And it's so easy to just over-correct
and over... yep, there we go.
- If we want to know how the
brain works in space flight,
we need to approximate the
whole variety of conditions and forces
without limiting it to just one axis.
So we started designing
a Multi-Axes Rotation and Tilt system,
which we call MARTS.
It became operational about 12 years ago,
and about 10 years ago we
flew it on the Vomit Comet,
it was actually the
biggest piece of equipment
and the heaviest that they flew.
- Okay, okay, okay, okay.
- What parabolic flight gives us is
the ability to test, in close proximity,
several gravity-inertial force
environments.
I flew a lot in zero G,
I probably have more zero G time clocked
than some astronauts.
- So this chair is balanced
on a metaphorical knife edge,
and my job is to keep it upright,
but I can't shift my body weight,
and I've got no cues
from my eyes or my ears.
Instead, all I have is this joystick,
and you know what?
I don't think I'm doing too badly at this.
- Your inner sense of balance
is inside your inner ear,
and your otolith organs
are these little hairs
that tell you how much you tilt.
In the upright, those hairs
tilt the more you deflect
and you have a good
sense of where you are.
When you're on your back,
the only thing that you really
have through your canals
and even through your skin is velocity.
So I take the people and I tilt them
until they're on their back,
and because I'm not tilting
relative to gravity anymore,
you can't really use gravitational cues
to figure out where you are,
and people become wicked
spatial disoriented.
- Whoa, okay.
- You know, I put pilots inside there,
they don't know where they are,
90% of people have no idea.
And one of the core things
I was very interested in
was how do people learn over time?
People in the upright who have
a good sense of where they are,
I was curious, well, what
does learning look like
even in that condition?
Because no one had even looked at that.
And so we took data and we
3D-printed each of the trials.
So this is trial one,
and this is going all
the way up to trial 20.
And if you have huge circles,
that means you're really bad.
And as time goes by, people learn.
In the beginning people come
in and they're stressed out,
you know and what they do
is they grasp that joystick
and they are just doing
these crazy manoeuvres
thinking that they need to
respond to every small thing.
Pretty rapidly, people are
able to learn to do this task.
This is our spaceflight analogue task,
this is when you're on your back.
You don't have gravitational cues
that tell you about your angular position.
It is just a mess.
People are in it for 40 minutes
and very very minimal learning.
There are some small
things that they learn,
and that's what I use to
create a training programme
that's actually effective.
And these red marks here
are destabilising joystick deflections.
This is when you make a
deflection of the joystick
that actually throws you
away from the balance point.
Because you're kind of disoriented.
- Did I just steer into the floor?
- Based on what I've been looking at,
there are really two
times that this happens.
One is just some weird freak thing,
where they're just like -- krushk! -- you know,
and who knows why that happens.
We need to study more, we want to
do imaging and things like that.
But the second time it happens is timing.
People are doing this joystick deflection
and they sort of hold onto
the joystick a little too long
and that becomes destabilising.
- This is impossible.
- I look at learning,
I look at how do you create
effective training programmes,
and I also look at: can we do
technological countermeasures
that can help people in that condition.
- Thank you to all the team
of the Spatial Orientation Laboratory
at Brandeis University.
Pull down the description
for more about them
and their work.
That is genuinely impossible.
...I'm talking really loud.
[laughter]
Cool.